you guys obviously are at the forefront
of the industry in terms of
hearing about what's going on and what
cgi can do
um what what has happened in the last
year or two that has really excited you
with technology
and what do you think is about to happen
in the future that might be able to
impact what we get out of movies or what
we can do in movies
if anything in my world i mean there are
things that i've observed that
uh it's cool to watch people do them but
i'm not necessarily looking to do it
myself
uh we've actually gone more practical
with every
uh jurassic movie we've made since the
first one and we have more animatronics
than this one
uh than we have in the previous two um
and
and
the thing that that i found just
especially in you know in working
uh in the past couple of months is that
we finally reached a point where it's
possible to
that digital extensions on animatronics
will be able to match the texture
uh and and the the level of the fidelity
uh that uh on film an animatronic is
going to be able to
bring and you didn't used to be able to
really mix them
like you could really see that you could
really see the seams uh
and so that part of it is is very
exciting for me and then also just in
the context of our stuff we've
jay bayona really uh he found the value
in creating
uh really photo real just beautiful
lighting references that that could be
articulated just slightly just a just a
head and a jaw that could move
and the ability to but but painted
beautifully hand painted
and we do it for all of the dinosaurs
now so we put it into a space
you can see how the light you know
reacts to the skin like and
uh when even if they ultimately do make
that
you know a digital animal there was
always something there
you know reacting to the light in that
environment uh
that has proven to be just puppetry in
general really simple puppetry has
proven to be
amazing